en avant marche allez on y va
c'est une rentrée millimétré au pas bien
décidé une démarche au carré le colle
bien plier tous les détails comptent
ces cinquante petits nouveaux ont
seulement 11 ans et c'est uniforme sera
désormais leur seconde peau sipa très
classique mais on est fiers parce que
c'est
on a beaucoup travaillé pour pouvoir
entrer dans cette école et puis
aujourd'hui c'est y est on est là et
c'est on a réalisé notre rêve donc on
est très fier de le porter
si jamais cet après midi vous êtes
perdus vous venez nous voir au bureau ne
pleurait la chef de peloton c'est un peu
la maman de la troupe
elle rassure mais doit surtout
transmettre la rigueur vous savez déjà
vous mettre au garde à vous on est
d'accord est en position de repos bien
le rythme compliqué à 6h30 du matin de
vous jusqu'à l'étude du soir jusqu'à 19
heures donc c'est des grosses journées
donc au fur et à mesure ça va ça va
venir ça va rentrer dans trois semaines
y'a pas de soucis il faut déjà connaître
tous les rouages de l'établissement aux
portes du morvan
le collège militaire situé en contrebas
de l'emblématique lycée est un
établissement quasi unique et très
demandé les règles de vie au sein du
collège
vous en connaissez déjà certaines ici
quasiment seuls les enfants de
militaires et de fonctionnaires peuvent
avoir leur chance
les élèves viennent ainsi de toute la
france c'est le cas des tas originaire
de lyon et m'a raconté sa ma ps3 quels
sont les autres collèges pour la
réputation travailler tous ne rêve pas
d'être militaire loin de là c'est
simplement suivre une scolarité un peu
autrement c'est la cohésion le respect
beaucoup d'insistance sur le respect le
respect bien sûr de l'adulte des
consignes mais le respect aussi entre
eux donc il ya souvent un important
travail qui est fait
loin de leur famille elles les élèves
sont ensemble 7 jours sur 7 24 heures
sur 24
de quoi renforcer l'esprit de groupe tu
fils unique et moi j'ai toujours voulu
savoir ce que c'est qu'avoir un frère
une soeur béatrice y va ça me fait
penser cela les parents y vont beaucoup
nous manquer
pour moi c'est d'à côté d'un côté ciel
c'est positif parce que c'est nous
rapproche de la maturité
depuis deux ans cette école de
l'excellence affiche un taux de réussite
de 100 % au brevet des collèges